[Music]
welcome to rippln Griffith
[Music]
and I want to introduce to the program a
very special guest mr. Billy Gardell
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my favorite this is Eli and
Robert you know that was so good I just
it's the first time I've used one twice
and I think that's the one people always
say that after then but then these
people they send in and then I hear
another one and I'm like blown away by
that one but hey guys if you really want
to send in a theme song you've got to
beat this one Eli and Robert came with
the Thunder funk so but anyways my good
friend visit Gardel is here why I'm
great I'm so glad you're here I don't
think people what do people know about
you you don't mean like where'd you
start I just lay low lay low lay low
stay out of trouble no I remember one
time I remember remember when I was
doing that show with am ed I'm ed out in
in Newport Beach I do remember that you
came out and did a show and it was Craig
it wasn't no it wasn't Craig for who was
a who was there with you that he was
headlining the show oh I forgot who it
was but anyways you went on before him
and just like to hope obliterated the
place like an old days he kept saying
over and over your dogs did
I started in yeah where'd you start
Orlando Orlando Florida you started in
Orlando yeah we had a pretty amazing
open mic crew our open mic night was
well let's see there was a couple guys
ahead of us like Tom Rhodes was already
a feature I mean this is 1987 Wow
so Dan Whitney who became Larry the
Cable Guy was a feature but those guys
were around to kind of help us a little
bit and but our open mic crew was me
Darrell Hammond let's see a guy named
Fillmore it was very talented cat who
ended up doing well at Nickelodeon and
stuff like that and let's see carrot top
oh geez and yeah was gonna make any
money and of course I was last to the
party but I made it but but it was it
was a great group of guys man we just
had this this crew that was kind of
eclectic and really helped each other
and we were that group that like we do
our open mic night and then we'd be at
Denny's with you know napkins like this
don't work for my act was do that no
this doesn't happen oh no it doesn't it
really doesn't happen and even know so
wonder when did you decide that like
Orlando was uh you you were big fish in
a little pond why I never I don't know
that I ever was I think I a Florida
comics like we had this thing on us like
and and I know roads felt this and Daryl
felt this and like you had to prove
yourself when you went somewhere else if
you were a Florida comic so we had a we
had a little bit of a chip on our
shoulder coming out on the road to do
really good shows and something we had
some great comics on I mean cats like
Danny Bevins down arrows I just think
it's wonderful and you know the Regan's
came out of there Brian and Dennis Regan
oh wow so Florida had this cool little
undercurrent of comedy and then I was
down I started in 87 by 91 I went to New
York City and I was living in this
dude's garage out on Long Island
for a little while first place I went up
there was in Huntington a place called
the Eastside comedy club which is
actually where Eddie Murphy started and
Rob Bartlett is right in the thick of it
but he goes oh but I started out at the
east side that was the first place I did
up north and then eventually I moved
into the city the second year I was up
into New York area I moved into the city
and just got my ass handed time just it
was different oh well I thought I was
you know you think you're funny in
Florida you were funny in Florida inform
you you're not and I just got my ass
handed to me in New York City and it was
probably one of the best things that
could have happened to me because when I
left New York I had this place at sixth
in Houston which was right above
Alphabet City and now if you go there
cuz I love to go visit New York I love
New York City you know go get lost there
I like jazz and I like steaks I'm very
lame hard to get that way love it by the
way have you been to that jazz BBQ place
yes what's the call I know exactly your
time I went there with Loomis still and
the guy played Vince on my komali he's
another jazz guy I was just there Hiller
and I will or smog a jazz place every
four feet so that's it right but this
it's just specifically ribs that's it
when we go to New York together we hit
they see us coming they get very excited
very
I know we're gonna make profit tonight
yes sir but I lived a buck sixth in
Houston at this I just I was on the
third floor of this building which was a
walk-up and for a fat guy you literally
will go
I might just sleep on a sidewalk and
then you hear a gunshot you gotta think
this snaps but Alphabet City was crazy
back then so it's funny to walk through
that neighborhood now cuz I go visit
there now and it's like those apartments
are now 38 hundred for a single yeah I
don't even think mine was legal like I
had this one of them apartments that
some dude it just yeah it's an apartment
you know there's a hole a janitor's and
a shower yeah for like 1,200 a month and
I barely made it
but New York taught me to I had to
really re-evaluate and decide what I was
gonna do after I left New York I left
New York because I just couldn't make it
there I couldn't I couldn't I just
couldn't make enough money to survive
and so I went back down to Florida and
kind of reevaluated and by that I mean
got high for about three years and then
I decided Artemus start taking this
seriously and I went to Atlanta and I
met my manager Krista Padova he loves
you to death
yeah and had the punch line and I went
up there and he signed me and then then
we just started working on you know what
I wanted to say what I wanted to be and
what direction I wanted to go and then I
think from there probably took about
another six years so total with ten on
the road and then I finally came out to
LA and I want to say ninety six under
ninety six beginning of 97 and then
another short 12 years yeah and then and
then was lucky enough to hit it on Mike
and Molly
yeah Wow wait a minute yeah there's more
stuff before Mike and mom well there I I
was when did you like you how's the king
of pilots you along yeah you were the
original pilot Kim I was like oh yeah
you did not just posit you did like you
were there mister are we gonna do a
season two this well you know my number
was this is so funny because my number
was 13 yeah that's as far as I'd ever
got yeah we did 13 on a show called
lucky I love John Corbett Craig Robinson
and we were me and Craig were you know
we were just new to the game but we had
this great chemistry and yeah this the
show was great it was written by Robin
mark Cullen it was about two years
before the World Series of Poker craze
had we been on that
and it was a great show on it was a
great show but I got that that was on
what network I was on FX
it was my FX right after the shield
right and right after the shield so we
were like that Chloe it was during the
shield like a shield to come out it was
out for a year and we're the next
project this is this is them trying to
get into the drama game right and and
the president of that company then took
a job at Fox so that was a and so you
know when the new guy comes get rid of
all the old blood and what really [ __ ]
out of here and what really sucked was
that show got nominated for a best new
comedy series Emmy and they cancelled us
a week later so there's no rhyme or
reason they don't even do that anymore
[Laughter]
they don't make that mistake guest star
like I tell you it was really great to
me who my college education was was Greg
Garcia who created yesterday or my name
is Errol and great are raising hope I
did a pilot for I love the guy and he
put me on yes dear as a reoccurring
character and that was like a real
education that I didn't know then was
getting me ready for Mike and Molly yeah
and then when you hit Chuck Lorre that's
like that's like playing for the Yankees
man yeah do you ever give any
suggestions - Chuck yeah no it's like
play for the Yankees we don't need any
help on the pitches man don't play third
base you were like I was taking my Lane
that's it man how was that working with
Melissa McCarthy she was awesome dude
she was awesome to this day the whole
cast we all still stay in touch that's
good I had dinner with her about six
months ago in New York City and I talked
to Reno all the time I was now on a show
called the good girls on NBC oh yes and
me and him you know Reno and me are a
great story because you know we had ten
years before Mike and Molly we were on a
show called the heist now that that was
a show that was on opposite they put us
on opposite American Idol at it well
that's why no one you could hear the
drums beating from episode one during
the first table read you guys it's not
gonna work did you say Wednesday at 9:00
so they put us on and we were still
getting six million people a week which
nowadays oh you'd be a hit that'd be
ambien
network smash but back then 10 was the
yeah the watermark so but me and Reno
stayed friends and we struck up a great
friendship we only did six episodes but
we became good friends and then our kids
were born about the same time like a
brother we've been so tight so 10 years
later I'm getting packed to go to tell
my dumb little jokes in Cincinnati or
somewhere and it calls me and he's like
hey just do this shows us we are Mike
and Carl going in on this thing called
Mike and Molly you got to get your agent
I got [ __ ] to do I gotta get my shave
kit felt yeah so I come back and ask
about it and and I get the audition I
get an appointment set for my agent Paul
Santana and who by the way I went back
to I went back to my original agent and
oh you had left him yeah I left him at
the third year Mike and Molly and it was
the real really the only blemish I feel
I've had in my career because I drank
the kool-aid
you got a the big now the big ages okay
you got to get a big and once I did I
might as well been in Iowa somewhere
because nobody it just wasn't working
and then I went to UTA who was very very
good to me and then once this deal with
Chuck came through for UTA I've left
that on the table with them and I said
look I appreciate everything you guys
have done but I'm gonna go back to my
original agent because I just think it's
right so I'm back with him now which I'm
really really happy to be back over
there because we wrote a dude that dude
just the old school loyal guy I am man
and that was the blemish on me because I
drank all the kool-aid some of that
money to like he was like I said he's
got the original mission said I got the
Rena go yeah so I'm hoping on this next
show I leave the original with over
there and he'll get to renegotiate
already landed a little something over
at APs since I've been home good for you
this guy my agent Paul man he went in
the early days like he would get me in
on something if there was that much
chance that I could be in the room he
got me in there even on the things that
were wrong got me in front people
well you know we didn't really want to
see you but hi fun the funniest one I
ever did was for Desperate Housewives
and I ended up booking the job it was an
FBI guy that's the bug a house right and
and everybody it's just ripped up
muscular dude and then I walk in like
John Candy like hi but your name's Chad
alright but I got the part but he would
do things like that and I just always
felt really terrible it was a business
move that I kind of had to make but
didn't want to and I owned it and I just
I went back to him about a year later I
said look man I'm really sorry that I
did that and I said in some day I'm
gonna come back and he said the doors
open and this year we were able to do
that so I'm back at home there and I'm
happy about that but I want to get back
to Reno Sereno calls me about that thing
called you about my c'mon yeah but then
I'm just hopeless I don't even think
nothing's gonna happen right so finally
I call and I get in and and we end up
getting on the show together which is
just a ridiculous that's a ridiculous
odds to to know someone that well and
then have them playing your friend your
best friend that's why we could finish
each other sentences on that we weren't
really acting you know but the greatest
was and we always tell this story and he
does to men the the week we did the
pilot I can't remember who was who it
was either his car was getting
repossessed and my transmission was
going or my car was getting repossessed
and his transmission was going I can't
remember which and we literally rolled
into the lot carpooling together that
whole first seven or eight episodes just
like Fred and Barney just barely good
well I could not believe that the gate
was gonna go up right right just pulling
in and came in was just kind of like I
was blown away and then I could not I I
was like is this gonna continue and when
are you putting them under your bathroom
you know what I did the whole time for
Mike Hamoui I took a page out of Leno's
book man I really knew that look all
right this window is gonna open and it
stays open a different amount for
everybody like it opens and closes
sometimes it blows open and you get
Melissa's career yeah phenomenal that's
rare air and then there's the dudes who
I like to you know I'm like a rounder I
grind just keep that window open I'll do
what I got to do it's like football you
know
yes keep icing your knees yeah better
yeah so I what I did was man I gave my
wife the paycheck because she's really
good with money and I just took five
hundred bucks cash a week and then when
the show was over because of the success
of the show is able to do stand-up at
casinos yeah stuff like that yeah so I
live on the stand-up money and all that
other money's put away for when we're
old and for my kids college it for you
some investment that's all her she did
all that make no mistake like if it was
me I would have had a hot-air balloon
so she's responsible for all that
happened but me and Reno man we were
just like Fred and Barney going into
work which is great and we still laugh
about it now yeah but it turned out to
be like a huge success yeah a great show
and it reached across the country of
reached across different age groups
which I loved like when I'd go to yeah I
go to my show and it was nice because
you'd see people that were 16s people
that were 20 and then what's happening
mental is kind of like I'll have young
people bring their parents to my show
which is kind of cool because we were a
show they all watched as a family and
right that was that that's when you've
hit some some rare error which analyze
what you feel about at the time that it
was like you were gonna be a fat guy on
TV and like to show what I think what
was that what was that dynamic in terms
of life with you even even with Melissa
at the time well both of you yeah the
the idea was always two people that
would thought they were never gonna fall
in love finding love that's all that was
always the baseline but we had to no pun
intended address the elephant in the
room
and so they had to pepper a little bit
of that the first season just to get
people because usually you know man
we're out here we're walking around most
leading men are 85 pounds and wear
medium t-shirts for anyway but so you
have to fight that a little bit so just
I think to get to get them used to us we
had to do a little bit of that that
joking as we went the first but the more
the show went on the more it became
about it didn't matter it was about love
there's all those about love and then
and then Chuck would always say that me
and Reena were the SEC
marriage of that show yeah because I got
your best friend that it's just giving
you advice about things he knows nothing
about and we just did that I thought
wonderfully when we had a rounded out
cast that was great Cleo King played his
grandmother who's an amazing actress and
Ronde Reid who forgot a Steppenwolf and
Swoosie Kurtz who's off a Broadway so we
had these and Lou who played Vince Li
and Katie mix and like we had all these
actors not like ass these were like
actor actors like and you know and then
I came out of a basement of a comedy
club that's great ya know but like in
terms of like so did you always want to
be an actor though or yeah is it oh you
did know yeah always always
um and it's funny because I've done
everything backwards I like I did I did
I did
my show and then I got a special I you
know went on The Tonight Show and I did
panel before I did snack like my
standards always I've always been like
one molecule off of being really famous
is standard and it's funny I'm not
complaining I'm so grateful for what's
happening beyond beyond but it's funny
because it's it that just like I still
have people come and go you do stand-up
yes so that's in I've been doing a 30
years but that's kind of funny to take
care of that you know people think like
oh that's your big break that should
think it wasn't a big TV thing but like
I was doing Stan grindin they don't even
know you get on once you get on TV they
don't realize what's behind how you even
got there was a stand-up god you're
standing yep you know so it's just it's
such a weird thing what do you think of
the business now the state of the
business I'm Harrison to where you were
when you first started you know man I'm
I admire the innovation of the younger
generation right now because I think
they're fighting a lot more to just get
heard than we are because it's such a
vast universe now like there's so many
avenues of I don't know how you get
noticed anymore and then you know the
clubs have you gotta start a podcast she
think the podcasts have brought
stand-ups back to the forefront I think
they're that because they are
good comedian is this is a great home
for them yes this is a great that's what
we do and that'll translate out into the
crowds but like nowadays you know you to
get notice it's it's a bigger deal like
we had you know we had showcase nights
at The Improv where sometimes you'd get
a little industry to come look at you or
or you know and and then I feel for
comics trying to start on the road now
because like when when I started yeah
you built your audience on the road not
but even before that like just to get
into the club like you had to have
another headliner say I'm gonna call
comedy off Broadway for you can you
drive through there Thursday and do ten
minutes in front of the owner right and
then he'll decide whether or not he's
going to book you like that's they don't
have that I'll do that now it's like two
giant comedy chains out there The Improv
and the funny bone and and while it's
made the club's nicer and bigger
breaking into that a lot tougher because
you go well I'd like to work for you in
st. Louis or Wisconsin or or wherever
okay well you have to go to LA to let
them know and let them see what you do
and then we'll talk about like I don't
know how big yeah there wow they they're
like how many followers do you have now
well that's the thing they're like how
many followers yet what do you do you
haven't you know it's like I just feel
if it was up if I had to start that way
I don't think I want to mean it I want I
almost often think that a lot of the
greats do we have to write even right
now line to man what did they have
wouldn't it have been different
no it's too much work for me I wasn't
done I mean it's a lot man it's like I
feel like people used to build their
audience on the road and then it got
introduced to TV yeah I remember now TV
you have to have TV to get on the road
without question question and and I
remember like it was starting I remember
about I guess about nine or ten years in
where with it started with comics
leaving and I always thought those guys
were ahead of the game and I would
always be like because I was drinking
yeah but um like guys guys off but guys
were guys were leaving the email cards
I'll tell you building their list that's
really good business I'm not gonna do it
but that's really good business
yeah really smart I thought that was
smart men you've watched it evolve into
social media yeah it turned into exactly
I remember that email list I know my
email from my email list then it became
like an in MySpace and it's something
like Dane Cook you know who I had on he
said he came on - it's like someone did
something like myspace came out then he
saw that it was like oh this is look how
many people this is touching right right
I can I can I have direct access to the
fans
now I mean that's the only thing -
though the good part about it is it's
taken out the middleman like we can
actually go you know you have we're one
away from all of our fans now yeah
you're that your closer now to access to
your fans and you've ever been before
which is a good thing I think that's for
for performers I think that's a great
thing but you're still in there you're
entrenched you know you know I'm I'm so
grateful for what happened to me Eric I
you know I'm just uh we're more of my
passion lies now is Mannheim I want to I
want to start producing I want to be I
want I'll of television so I'm gonna do
a new pilot with Chuck and Chuck Lorre
and I don't mean to sound out like a
Hollywood [ __ ] I'm gonna be doing a
new pilot with Chuck but he was kind
enough to to ask me to do another show
with him which I'm just blown away and
honored by and the man changed my life
beyond but what I did during my Kamali
was I sat like Jimmy burrows directed us
for the first two years who directed
cheers friends yeah yeah he's the king
and and I sat and I asked him questions
every day when people were at lunch and
I've watched Chuck and I've asked Chuck
a lot of questions so I I looked at it
like you know the email thing that I
missed well I got this one yeah because
what I did was after networking never
has gone away well it's always just even
education yeah these are two of the best
men in television so I thought if I'm on
this show I'm not gonna you know I'm not
gonna just let this go wait there's an
education to be had here too and so
that's where I'm trying to get to next
like I sold a pilot with a friend of
mine at CBS about three years ago we
didn't get the pilot however we now have
we just got a deal put in place with
Lionsgate for a new show that I have and
we're gonna take that out and I think
this one has a real good shot of getting
on the air ooh
there'll be a part for me yes there will
be yes sir
you have it on your podcast I'm a fan I
know you extra know what you actually
Billy actually came to my show that and
then comics just don't do now we
understand gel we do we understand what
you said I remember that you called me
like hey can you give me two tickets and
I was like you my mind I was like he's
not gonna you know wasn't for someone
else one of the one of the the things
that was fun about the old days that I
don't see that I wish was more around
these days is you kind of went and
watched guys that were really good
because it inspired you and so I keep an
eye out for comics and inspiring because
I lose sight of the fact that I should
be having fun up there I lose sight of
it you working all the time I feel like
it's working and so when I watch a guy
that makes me forget and I just get to
enjoy his stand-up to me that that's
important so I watch you I've come to
see your shows I'm a big fan of Bill
burr yeah yeah bill Tom Segura I think
lately is just fantastic I like I like
Steve Byrne I like Nick Griffin so I try
to watch guys that inspire me like when
I did this tour called the Jameson tour
the comedy tour for a whiskey company
for about four years and for the first
year I got on that tour I was completely
burnout like I was like I can't say
another fun I was it was that kind of
set you having when you're doing your
set
you're killing yeah but in the back of
your head like you say this again and
then I worked with Danny Bevins and Nick
Griffin and Steve burn and I have to say
this guy's rien spired that's good
to get hungry because it was fun to
watch them every well here's the thing
you haven't done in a while and I'll
tell you what you're missing in your
what I miss is you don't go to the clubs
man don't you don't go to the club so
this thing that you're talking about and
it's happening right now it's like a
it's like a new boom yes that's not I
love you Donna ROM White's Donna Joey
Diaz is done I mean there's all the
gangs
all here a lot of new guys out there
they really just sitting in the back
watch now here's the problem here's
here's what went wrong you get
successful uh-huh
you get a little soft yeah at least I
did you know and and and the other part
is and this is a soft you just
comfortable I'm just old if my shoes are
off by 7:00 p.m. is it no chance street
lights Steve Burns always trying to get
me that kid out you've got it can Alonzo
Bolden's always like come on want to at
three o'clock in the afternoon Eric I
watch yeah but the other side of that is
my son is 15 and he is the absolute most
important thing in my life
and I'm becoming a family guy I just
wanna be home man I want to see him at
the table doing his homework I got yeah
I want my wife to come tell me how she's
disappointed in me but you know and then
I want to just watch a little TV and do
my crossword no but I tell just I'm lame
brother I like being lame you could get
on at 10:45 oh man I'm asleep tired yes
Lee at 10 o'clock
terrible it's terrible it's a grand part
you want to get it it is but here's
where I'm finding it in other places
like I still love the hour of doing
stand-up on stage I still love going to
do that there's nothing like it and when
you're if you're blessed enough to be
good at stand-up there's nothing like it
yes there's not I don't care what
anybody says there's nothing like it but
I think I've found this new excitement
in trying to write and put projects like
and it's the same kind of passion I had
to get to open mic night in the old days
so that's kind of where I'm trying to go
I don't know if that's going to happen
but that's where I'm trying to you know
what I know exactly how you feel
actually because we know myoh younger
younger days when I was coaching
basketball
remember when I was in high school I
played basketball and then kind of
thrill I got a rush yes but I gotta be
in there gonna be in lab the bad the
rebound and I would done my thing would
be I would grab it I would yell you know
every time I got a rebound to try to
intimidate people around me right but I
remember when I got into coaching I had
the same thrill like if I drew up a play
for the kids and they ran it and scored
I would be on the sideline like yeah and
I thought I was like oh this is that you
can't have that same yes I I know what
you're talking about it's just it's kind
of transferred location yes but yeah but
I still that that that really excites me
trying to get a script and pitch it and
get it sold and then I eventually want
to get those executive producer
headphones that's what I'm shooting you
talking about not doing we're gonna have
another conversation you're gonna be
like do anything look for the last job
we never we ever need yeah and you got
that one I did you got the last job
you'll ever need it now everything now
is these are the things that you want so
what I want to do yeah exactly exactly
so you've been married how long I've
been we're coming up on 18 years 18
years of marriage and been together for
almost 20 and I've got a 15 year old and
I love it man
I just love being home I love being safe
I love being quiet and you must have
found a good one that a lot because you
were real romantic yeah she's been
tremendous man the first eight years of
our marriage was just so beautiful and
then and then I got out of hand for
about three years with the drinking oh
wow but then I got sober I've been sober
for 11 so congratulations thank you bro
we're in a really sweet spot oh and I
should give a shout-out to the Chrysler
Bert Kreischer to Bert because he was
super fun to have on the Jameson Tour -
he was
this is like oh you know know what's
gonna I don't know I in fact and is so
huge infectious and you can see why he's
so successful now but I didn't want to
follow that because I'm old my egos gone
so I was headlining that tour till he
came on I was like Burt I'm not you do
you think brother that go do it and then
I would go in the back to watch because
you just don't know what is gonna happen
I loved it you know what I feel like I'm
already like that and I'm not even big
like if I want to show with people I'm
gonna be like they like Oh who's gonna
go up first I'll go up first I don't
care but see that's a veteran things
know how much time do I have to do you
know I asked this when do you want to
show the air I'll stop mid Joe yeah one
time I was I was in Seattle coming up I
was always like this and then like yeah
you had to do the underground and the
guy John Fox would have you you would do
the underground but then he would have
you drive a hundred miles to some [ __ ]
location in Washington to do some bar
okay so I'm doing this bar show when the
comic that's with me he's he's feeling
himself he loves notebook I said what
time to show got it in yeah he told me
that yeah it's too hard out cuz we got
this other thing and I said perfect no
problem he's killing Billy I'm in the
back going like this so I end up only
doing 15 minutes right you know so we're
in the car and he's like pumped up you
know and I'm counting the money good
money I'm like I think I messed up yeah
I think I did more work than they
deserved I think I got I didn't want
worried that you need that period of
your life to but I'm with you these I'm
like 10 or more
we're gon give you you could be in
midlife so then my wife oh you know so
do you and did you do you appreciate now
like because because obviously the
crowds have gotten bigger or the shows
have gotten less that that's what it
isn't like before when you have to do
seven shows Tuesday night to Sunday yeah
now you're just like in the casinos and
the big theaters and yeah but I'm
starting to wane a little bit like it's
funny because like during my Kamali
about the third year it got really
popular and like you know you know
nice-size house is 1500 to 2000 that's
about where I peaked at and then now
I've been off the air for about three
years and so now the ticket sales
weaning just a little bit you so so now
you got to find you either gonna find
something new to spike them back up or
you've got a the social media thing and
I'm doing some clubs as well you know
but I'll do whatever it takes it doesn't
matter you love you still love doing
Stan I love doing the stand-up I don't
like being gone a lot so that so your
other point I love that I can fly out do
again come back and then I've been I've
done some corporate gigs which I love oh
okay like a tire company or something
forty minutes yeah you find out who to
you find out who the president is
there's dick Johnson over there people
love when you roast the president of the
company and you do it right you for free
tires on top of your yeah but let me ask
you this though man what do you what do
you feel about the like the state of the
sensitivity in doing comedy you are
you've always been a sort of clean the
middle of the road yeah yes I'm in that
Club I mean I'm a swear a little bit but
none of my material really comes from
where you're gonna get combative or do
you ever want to go in that direction or
do you write you know when I was younger
I did but I I'm always a believer that
you kind of write what's going on in
your life and that's the school I came
from and what you know my life is about
being married for a long time my life is
about being a father and not a hypocrite
so so I think I think we have to be
careful with being too sensitive around
humor and
I think if you're humorous you have to
have judgment and I think I think that's
where the balance is yeah I feel there
are some guys that can talk about
politics and not make you want to run
out of the room or in Patton Oswalt's a
genius that guy knows how to do that I'm
not smart enough to do that right I can
tell you about being married for seven
so that's what I do
do you know what I mean so so I think
I've always looked at comedy a lot like
music especially like jazz I mean you
just got to find what your sound is and
play your sound you know what I mean and
that's the day yeah I feel like I think
what you're saying too is like we just
have to be more thoughtful like I don't
think we have to like shy away from
subjects but we definitely need to be
you guys think about how you go into
that so yeah yeah I know because
especially with like the me to movement
and all that it's like you know you know
we could male comedy it's you know we
stole sometimes or some massage in this
day core so just you know it's like
sexual there's a good reason going on
that's and there's all just a great way
to put it
we educate and you meet and we need that
and we need to know what and what
frightens me is how far as a society we
have forgotten how to be compassionate
or kind especially around race or the
gay culture or or women we got to grow
up man we I I feel like we used to know
a little better and I feel like we're
going to right direction and I had I'm
not so sure we are right now I think
it's it's gotten hateful and ugly out
there and I think any time that you can
can can find a way to to bring love to
bring compassion I think you're doing a
far more noble thing than you are
driving your point home well said my
friend I got after that I know I man
that's what it's about now I totally
understand what you're saying and I even
to take it even further I even feel like
maybe that we haven't lost the education
but now what I look back and realized
that we weren't educated or women we it
was we didn't see what was going on
because you know when you see these
lists of like people that have been like
taken down by you go WOW will we will
wreak implicit in this for so long
why
I've always been on the outskirts so I
don't know as much as everybody else
does but it all shout me when I would
hear something and somebody go oh
everybody knew that right rock didn't
know that nobody's talking to me man I
did that I think I tweet every six days
I'm so bad at it switch gears like so
did your son help you with that I was
like is he like being it like
interaction nah man him man I I don't
talk too much show business with him
other than the fact he wants to get into
acting who loves the theatre at school
am I gonna tell him that'll never work
out yeah if it worked out for you look I
said look man just here's the here's
this change I would make you know you're
at 40 I thought everything was done I
thought there's no chance of anything
ever happening and I had no backup plan
and you know when you're starting you
here buddy girl you can't have a back-up
plan or you'll use it well that's
[ __ ] yeah you need it I would have
cut my arm off to have a back-up plan at
that time in my life so I said feel like
that right now go get a degree so even
if you don't end up in front of the
camera and I'm not saying you won't
you'll have something you could become a
teacher or maybe there's a lot of ways
to skin a cat in show business yeah yeah
yeah you could end up doing lighting or
sound or set or something might move you
that you didn't even realize even know
so be open to that you don't have that
experience and he's gonna get to go to
college which I never did so that'll be
important I could tell that it's
important yeah and you know what and
it's not even for these reasons you're
saying about having a back-up plan no
you want him to go to college because
you didn't get I didn't get that
opportunity and he I gotta tell you man
he's such a great kid he's 15 and he's
that he's I'm more proud of him than
anything I've done in my life is he a
big boy he's a little bulky yeah but I
mean that's genetics yeah so I told him
I said well look you know I go take care
of your body now because I didn't get
that note and we'll eat yourself out of
opportunity don't do that so take care
of yourself now and he's getting it and
he's got a 3.6 grade average he's no job
looking listen a problem
number 15 I'm already smoking weed
stealing beers this is a miracle that
you so the fact that he's getting this
life and I try to give him the questions
that weren't answered for me and I think
it's working out pretty good them does
he ever think about trying to be a
stand-up at all it's more acting but he
likes he likes being funny he likes
being funny so and and him and his
buddies are always trying to do little
videos and did he ever ask you to be in
a video I told him I would but he don't
that's you know it's so glad rather have
it that way I was what time I were like
Dana Carvey was there and he had his
kids you know his kids were there and
Dana Carvey he's talking he's talking
with us about something and his kids
were like dad you know I turned to no I
was like your father is a genius but
it's amazing that you're just dad I
think it's better that way in fact I
told him when Mike and Molly hit I said
because he said to me we were driving
home from school one day and there was a
big billboard of me and Melissa on
Ventura Boulevard I said where's your
famous now huh and I pulled the car over
I got hold up I said here's the deal I
got a really good job that I worked very
hard for and that doesn't mean that
deserved the job there's a lot of guys
in this town that are funnier than me
more handsome than me quicker than me
and younger than me I just happen to be
in the right place my place what time I
didn't quit so there's some luck
involved I said but all it is is a good
job that's what I do Who I am is your
father let's keep it right there and
stay humble be grateful for all the
gifts we've been given so and he kind of
took that to heart he's been good that
way that's great man I often say my one
of my sayings I've stolen in the past is
like people don't fail they quit mmm you
know and it's just some people fail but
but I'm just saying no yeah people just
go I can't do this anymore it's not
right to leave me and earthquake you
know earthquake oh yeah yeah we go way
back and you got a lot of black friends
very cool I'm very cool but quite used
to live across the street from me in
these apartments and our one rule was
don't get the phone cut off does in the
early it's too late you can get the
lights cut off yeah you can get the car
taken away they don't get the heat don't
get that phone cut off man that's how we
always looked at it like it's a casino
if you can just stay at the table
eventually you're gonna get a lot ahead
now it might not be the thing you want
but something will hit but you guys stay
in the casino yes how here you are like
some like you know cuz you've been in a
business now 30 years 32 32 years yeah
that is crazy you know well I hope that
that works out like that would you
become a producer and all this it's what
I'd like to go if it doesn't it's okay
to I'm just gonna watch my son do what
he does that's it do you do you have
like one of those moments in your career
where you were like like oh I can't I
don't want to do this anymore oh yeah
that like right before my komali
and I and I I've said that a couple
times on a couple of only done a couple
podcasts but Marc Maron's I we went into
this you did the big ones I'm so glad
you came on my little lesson now Marc
Marc asked me and I was honored that he
asked me cuz that what that guy does to
me is just other level yeah and and he's
he's gonna be the Godfather
oh yes and he's a great interview and
and I found myself being very
comfortable to be very honest with him
and and I what happened was towards the
end of like right before Mike & Molly
I was unemployable like I couldn't get
booked to book an acting job I don't
know what had happened but it was like
two years of nothing so I thought that's
over on the road it was that time where
you know clubs were cutting money and it
was hard to get a gig I was lucky enough
to still be on the Jameson tour but that
was ending and I had just had my son and
I thought I can't you yeah you can't
rely on leave these two out in the wind
hope and I'm gonna do something so I I
have a buddy in Pittsburgh Randy Bauman
at WDB and that's the biggest radio
station in Pittsburgh they're classic
rock they're not hate driven I love them
they're it's like going the Letterman
Show he really runs a tight ship
and I call in there every Tuesday still
do every Tuesday morning with him for an
hour get up at 5:00 oh wow I love
calling home and I said look man I think
I may need to come home can I get a job
on the morning show because I figured
then I could take care of my family
still have a creative outlet you make a
few bucks I'm in my hometown town yeah
and that would be awesome he said yeah
man I he goes I can work that out for I
said all right I must stay for one more
pilot season and in that pilot season in
that three months I got six auditions
where is nothing yeah six and three
months is a yeah yeah yeah the last one
was Mike and Molly you were packing
boxes yeah and then when we found out we
got picked up I was working and I was
having one of those comic nights man I
was working in a place in Milwaukee
where they got a comedy club that's
below a strip club yeah I don't think
they're any more good anyway no but I
was down there and you know it's them
clubs where them dudes are out of money
they run them downstairs for a comedy
show you can imagine how happy they are
so there's 12 of these dudes in a 300 C
room and I don't up on stage and I got
offstage and it was like 30 texts on my
phone I was like something happened and
it was everybody called to tell me hey
man the show got picked up we got 12
episodes we got 12 episodes and I just
could not I was blown like I couldn't
believe that it happened there was wrong
that's that's just one of those that's
one of those times you never forget
never this amazing always around and
outside it's always well stand up is who
brought me to the dance that's why I
will never disrespect it a root for the
younger guys I enjoy watching my peers
to try to stay inspired and I still like
to listen to the old records man I love
pride Carlin Newhart I still like to go
back early Rodney Dangerfield actually
Marin turned me on to this long-form
Rodney Dangerfield that I'd never heard
I didn't know that guy ever did long
form because by the time he was famous
was always one life yeah he had this
album or it's all long forms really so I
still enjoy going back to kind of listen
that stuff to kind of get that that
feeling of yeah you know I mean because
you're not going to the clogs
stay on me about it yes yeah you got it
you listen to the whole Rodney
Dangerfield which is great I'm not
saying taking anything away from it no
but someone show your face I should I'm
old and tired
I should all right you're right calling
me out of moaning oh man I remember my I
I remember cuz he when you were coming
out you were doing the Florida so when I
was coming up I had to do like the
Tribble runs in Montana and I did this
you did the trouble runs tribal runs oh
man and what was the other guy through
the Midwest the Lansing and the bowling
alleys and I never because I owed her
Yoda yes and then there was his runs his
kids runs kids were so I you know what's
funny man I owed him $300 on a
commission that I didn't pay for
probably out of 15 20 years did you pay
yeah I sent it yeah but I never heard
back from him so this is late yeah well
our words one of my worst gigs ever was
on a triple run there's a lot of comics
that would say well when I was coming up
to before Hef took over the comedy zones
and made it fun to work there again
there was a guy ran it before that boy
he would just put you in these these
gigs really like what you didn't realize
about those gigs were they weren't
actually comedy clubs it was yeah
but you know at the time but you thought
you were going to a comedy show yeah
yeah I wouldn't walk in here if I wasn't
doing now yeah but but those gigs they
it's a double-edged sword with those
rode gigs because it learns you learn to
toughen your metal so you're not afraid
of any crowd but at the same time your
material starts if you stay in that too
long yes your material starts to lean
towards appeasing that kind of show and
that hurts you when you come out here
because you have to be a little less
Road and a little different when you
come out here I find I think I'm finding
that like that difference between road
and not road is that the line is
blurring
just as it is nowadays because we're in
a different world of how you're seeing
when you're seeing where you're seen and
how you know what areas you have to work
to do that it's it is evolving yeah but
I think back then you know the road
comics we you know we kind of had the
same premises you know we just did
because that's where we were out living
and doing you know well a lot of people
like what do you do like a lot of people
gave me but you put your own stank on
things yeah well what I learned was a
lot of comics are married and they have
kids they talk about these things you
know I used to struggle with how am I
gonna find my original unique you know
all that [ __ ] I go through and about
around year 12 I found my voice the
twelfth year and I found it when I was
watching a late late at night there was
this vh1 we are one of those behind the
music things remember those yeah Carlos
Santana right is talking about there are
only so many notes okay everybody's got
to play E everybody's got to play GE
everybody's got to play a so the ABCD
efg how you tune the guitar is what
makes you different and he said so I
have to play E but you can tell my E
from Keith Richards E you can tell Keith
Richards E from Stevie Ray Vaughan's E
it's how you tune your guitar we're all
talking collectively about the same
things but how you approach it is what
makes you original and that kind of
freed me up to kind of be the goofy guy
I am well I know that now it's because
everything's on the Internet it's so
hard to like even feel original when
like you know you could put a clip up
and then all of a sudden like these
trolls are like sending out a yes you
stole this from from you know such a
such did I've never met before lives in
a place I've never seen I don't know
this person yeah it's like the end they
don't know that they don't we can't even
make the connection it's like a parallel
thinking is something they don't even
understand no and and then like you said
as a comic everybody's looking for the
next thing and so I try to just look the
comics been talking about being married
since in the 50s you know what I mean I
just talk about my marriage yeah he said
that's what makes it different yeah I
talk about my journey as a father that's
what makes it there I always say the car
I talk about me being literally
illiterate when it comes to technology
like I've just embraced
that it's passed me by yeah yeah just
embrace yeah you probably five years
when I have to get a new phone the
anxiety I can't but yeah now it's mean
you don't have a flip phone do you I
gave it up two years I held on for a
while two years ago yeah maybe for eight
maybe we're on iPhone 10 and you had a
flip phone two years ago no five years
even still I think that but I had I just
I'm not good at all that stuff and and
and you know I've always been even in
school and this is someone tried to
teach my son is you got to learn the
stuff that makes you uncomfortable and I
always found if I was interested in it I
could learn it if I wasn't I would just
block it out of my head that's dangerous
so I'm trying these days okay a little
more open-minded and learn new things
when it comes to technology so I was
gonna say it's not a big fan okay you
know I'm sure you don't get a lot of
hate tweets it's not mean I'm just
talking about when you see people
talking to each other yeah starts with
two nice sentences and just descends
into yeah
utter hate and I don't that baffles me
man there's a lot of wasted time there I
know a lot of ways I just know that from
like I know doing comedy for me like in
the last year it it was a it was a it
was difficult transition just because
like you know it's like you have half
the people love Trump half the people
hate Trump and then you have this like
you're in the clubs and you're like oh
god like that one sides too angry the
other side's too sensitive
yeah well and see I my feelings on that
personally are I'm not a fan of the guy
I would never vote for the guy I would
never support anything the guy says but
I also know that unless you have built
your following with the same opinion
it's hard when you have a group of both
sets of those people in the club because
they don't go after you take off after
each other yeah and you know that's just
that's a hard place to be it really is
that's also the beauty of stand-up
comedy is that you're in this crowler
house in st. Louis and it just was like
I got was just
triggering like everybody you know what
happened here you know you just
I wasn't even trashing the guy I just
was saying that some funny joke well
this lady was like [ __ ] yeah I was she
like stormed out this guy has said more
awful things than any president I think
we've ever had and yet you can't make
fun of him in front of his supporters
which which is like weak comedians have
been making fun of the president so I
don't know why he's hands-off especially
with some of the things that comes out
of his mouth but I think that goes back
to we have to really look at how we
treat each other these days man yeah I
have to really look at how we treat it
there's a rush to be right in this
country that's very dangerous and to be
first right at all costs to be first to
a topic and write about that tide at all
costs yeah and we don't want to say I
always said we're missing nuance we're
just missing kindness well that's what a
beautiful man you are about a man yeah I
get it I mean cuz I guess I'm still
fighting the good fight cuz I'm now I'm
out there you've seen my act you know
sometimes I'm talking about certain
things but you don't offend to me but
anyway but the thing is is like I in
fact you get away with a few things and
I'm like wow we got away with that Wow I
would never get away with that but
that's all about just being thoughtful
about it it's funny it's kind of putting
mine but it's craft there is a crazy I
agree as if you can deliver the that
that kind of truth look the truth
without love is abuse so if there's a
little bit of sweetness the medicine
goes down if you're just saying [ __ ] to
say [ __ ] yo asses yeah there are a lot
of castor oil comics out there there you
go you know it's good for you I guess
bitter in your mouth I mean I'll make me
laugh at some here's what I find man if
you want if you truly are trying to to
help somebody laugh it may be something
they're taken too seriously it's got to
be really funny it's got to be really
funny because that's the only way
they're gonna open up and go oh maybe oh
wait maybe I did look at that wrong yeah
I know but it's so hard because like we
live in this society of a hundred and
eighty characters and it's like we have
to somehow get all of
our opinions across in this short little
slice we don't I don't know if I'm right
I just know what brings me peace and I
and I have been given a gift of one
being sober and given a gift of a
beautiful family and success so I try
not to I try to find I try to leave
places better than I found them
oh look yes my gig I don't do it all the
time sometimes I want to burn the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
by the way speaking on that though is I
guess there is a certain expectation
that when you go to a place they're
thinking oh it's Mike yeah yeah you know
there is that there's um there's that
you know they don't expect you even
swear so I had to get by that'll say
some some swear words but you got to be
okay with that we're all adults here you
know you know but I did have to
acknowledge it for a long time because
like sweet it's again another challenge
you know and it was a healthy challenge
so I took to it pretty well I thought
well you taking on challenges all the
time now I feel you've been a prety
producer that thing know if you love it
it's not work I tell my kid that all the
time if you love what you're doing you
never work a day in your life man I
believe that too my god the big one that
I've been trying to do is that's
creeping up on me is health I've had I
got type 2 diabetes now oh yeah and you
know like so now my I have to confront
this one now this is the biggest one
this is the one I've had problem with my
whole life because I've been a big guy
in my whole life and then I got fatter
and I have to look at that and own it so
I can change it so I'm not riding around
and as a be hooked to a bag somewhere
when I'm 60 I work too [ __ ] hard foot
to get here right yeah I don't want to
be that guy so I'm trying to confront
this one now because this is the one
that well I know this it could take me
out of all the other things I want
if I don't pay attention well I know
this is this is a difficult journey and
I and I went sushi ate you talking about
weight is the hard part and I feel like
we have we're getting hoodwinked in
society with this whole like body
positivity no I'm not I'm with you I'm
what are you talking about [ __ ] we gotta
own it put your shirt on at the beach no
one wants to see you want to love you
that way I'm sorry I know that hurts
some sensitive ears oh but it's such if
you can't look at a one-piece body in a
two-piece but if you can't look at it
you can't change it and the truth to me
with weight is look and and I got some
[ __ ] that [ __ ] in my head cuz like I I
don't have the usual fat guy wolves I
had a good career yeah yeah yeah I know
what you're saying a pretty wife got a
healthy son got a successful life so I
don't have the usual in fact that [ __ ]
works against me because it's like you
made it as a big month those are two
different conversations yeah but they're
dangerous you know we all made it why
can't I still be fat I know but it can't
run from it you could be President and
not necessarily be a great person that
has your success has nothing to do with
like you know yeah that's justification
you know I don't believe in you got to
just love yourself and you got to look
at yourself and I gotta get this [ __ ]
together because that's not even loving
yourself if you don't it's not and
that's the wiring and and and getting
type 2 diabetes has really opened my
eyes to holy [ __ ] if I don't treat this
this will start eating at every organ
there's no [ __ ] around with this now
now I'm not gonna put myself in a pity
party cuz that just leads them rhyme
addict right and I'm not gonna say it's
as bad as having cancer it's not it's
something that can be managed but this
is my struggle this is liq did without
question and that's the thing we need to
work on as well that's that's owning it
look there's two different conversations
there's a conversation about what you
like is about being kind yeah about
being thoughtful so there's a way you
tell a fat person well because what
these people are confusing is like we're
being mean to fat people and we need to
stop that but at the same time we're
even
people can be paid honestly you need to
get your fat ass in the gym and work on
yeah and or say it like I care about you
and I want you to be here
Titus is great at that with me Chris
Titus always calls me just dude I just
want you around I just want your that's
a caring friend now
what I don't need is a skinny dude who's
never had problem telling me what I need
to do to lose weight unless you really
want to put your demon on the table yeah
yeah that's around holy [ __ ] that's good
but anyways to wrap it up you know I
just want to say I am I I wish you all
the best
gachi I'm a fan I remain ofin and we
bought you know and we both should
actually stay on each other about I
started boxing recently good but I keep
getting off of it because I got to
travel and things happen yeah but I got
to get back on it I got to stay healthy
be healthy you know and we have to
encourage people to do the same you do
it's it's no joke and you got it and the
hard part to swallow man for me is
because I grew up in Pittsburgh and then
oh yeah yeah down white trash in Florida
and so hearing you got to love yourself
enough to do this is a hard thing to
process but I'm getting there man sweet
somebody some other things have been
knocked on and if I could conquer them
there's no reason I can't get by this
but we have to also have to understand
what that really means loving yourself
is not being indulgent no so that's well
there you go
it's about actually you're doing the
hard things to make the hard choices you
know that that's exactly right and to
know that when I eat broccoli um that's
loving myself eatin pizza ain't reward
myself even oh I'm gonna get high eating
the pizza like that gives me an
endorphin pop I love that [ __ ] I love
food dude it's terrible oh I love it
me too so we just know we are Adoration
bro
I heard about I've never had one or
anything in my life huh so here's the
thing I we either have to love ourselves
and get healthy or we got to help Dale
chemical can make broccolini taste like
Cap'n Crunch
why can't things that be good for you
also tastes good yes well that's some
kind of cruel joke it's God's sense of
humor in my opinion a Twinkie should be
like you know vitamin know it's like
broccoli but you know a but but actually
an older age I have I find myself being
a more of our food connoisseur now I
love a good piece of broccoli yeah yeah
I'm still working on you don't go to you
know what his problem is you still got
that white trash yeah anyways but
anyways dude I really appreciate you
coming on I love you man's great talk
and we're gonna go to dinner or we're
gonna make sure we're healthy if you
don't allow me off again Oh bang bang oh
man but good luck with the TV show back
atcha good luck with the producing we'll
see I hope that we get to work together
we will I'm gonna have to send this to
Chuck Lorre and be like what he said
[Laughter]
video I hope to get to do something with
you hopefully we will get to work
together be great and I wish the best
for your son I hope that he has he
finishes his gets his degree at college
and it also goes into business yes you
know and we want
to get healthy I hope you fight this
dialogue more gonna work on that and I'm
gonna work on my thing and hey this has
been another great episode of riff with
Griffin inspiring the talented 32 years
in the business the thoughtful to
carrying my friend thank you thank you
for coming on this take Gardel thanks
Eric and you guys tune in next week and
thank you for watching I love all your
comments I love everything you're saying
and I'm gonna continue to do this I'm
like I'm not gonna quit you know people
don't fail it I'm not gonna summon them
I'm gonna stay in the podcast and the
casino all right goodbye thank you very
much
[Music]